just before we get started with today's
video i do want to give a quick plug to
my podcast the casual criminalist we
cover
a lot of crimes criminals bad things on
this channel
they always do well so i decided to do
something that just focused on all of
that dark stuff
that new podcast is longer form it runs
for about an hour it goes out every week
and it covers some of the darkest things
that i could find on the internet
from the uk doctor who was the worst
serial killer in history
to the time an american socialite
murdered her best friend with her car
allegedly and much much more but it's
also pretty laid back
more free form with the occasional
laughs thrown in because isn't death
hilarious
weekly shows wherever you get your
podcasts there are
links below
it seems that every year social media
and the news are full of stories and
panics about
trick-or-treating gone wrong children
being kidnapped while trick-or-treating
children being given
sexually explicit material instead of
candy by a house they visit but most of
all
stories of tainted candy treats that
have been laced with drugs like lsd or
marijuana razor blades embedded in candy
apples and
candy that's been poisoned by nefarious
entities
all of these urban legends have scared
american parents for years
leading to famous overreactions like
x-raying candy bags or
not accepting anything not in a
factory-sealed package or
some parents even forbidding children
from going trick-or-treating at all
but all of these stories have to come
from somewhere right
on halloween 1974 the parent's worst
nightmare came to life
an eight-year-old boy suddenly died
poisoned by cyanide it had apparently
come from
candy that had gotten while
trick-or-treating other children had
poisoned candy in their candy bags too
it sent america into a panic the very
idea that a random mad poisoner would
murder children
complete strangers with poisoned
halloween candy
uphold them but as police investigated
the death of timothy o'brien the story
that emerged
proved to be more sordid more horrifying
than
anyone could have imagined this is the
true story
of the pixie stixx killer
in 1974 houston texas was booming in the
past 20 years the population of the city
had more than doubled making it the
sixth largest city in the nation the
city which had been long sustained
by the shipbuilding and port trade was
now being supplemented by the aerospace
industry particularly nasa
based out of the johnson space center
and the petrochemical industry
big oil in the sleepy houston suburb of
deer park the o'brien family
seemed to have perfectly captured the
american dream ronald o'brien worked as
an optician at texas state optical tso
which made and sold eyeglasses he and
his wife daenell had two children
timothy age 8 and elizabeth age 5.
halloween 1974 had been fun for the
o'brien children the family had gone to
visit friends in the neighboring town of
pasadena and they'd gone
trick-or-treating there with their
father and a couple of other children
when they'd returned home that night
ronald o'brien allowed his children to
eat one piece of candy
each from their respective stashes
eight-year-old timothy selected
a pixie stix a flavored powdered sugar
candy and a plastic tube resembling a
straw
timothy swallowed a mouthful of the
candy and immediately complained that it
didn't taste right
it tasted bitter too bitter to be candy
his father gave him kool-aid to wash the
taste out of his mouth
but within minutes timothy ran into the
bathroom holding his stomach he threw up
and then he started convulsing then in
his father's arms he went limp and
became unresponsive
an ambulance was called but by the time
he reached the hospital timothy o'brien
was dead
[Laughter]
the suspicions of police about timothy's
death were soon confirmed an autopsy
showed the boy had been poisoned with
potassium cyanide enough to kill
two full-grown adults testing the pixie
stix revealed more cyanide enough to
kill another two adults
the news that a child had died after
eating tainted halloween candy
shocked the nation although urban
legends about a mad poisoner who killed
children with poison candy had been
passed around for decades in reality no
child had ever been poisoned by eating
contaminated trick-or-treat candy given
to them
by a stranger before houston went into a
panic the police department in pasadena
was inundated with trick-or-treat candy
from residents who wanted it tested for
poison
four other tainted pixy sticks were
found in the bags of timothy's sister
the two other children they had been
trick-or-treating with and another
family friend the murderer
had cut the tubes open dumping out the
top two inches of candy
and replaced it with cyanide and then
stapled the tubes shut again none of the
other children had eaten the candy but
one family was sent into a panic when
they were unable to locate the pixie
sticks that had been given
they rushed upstairs and found the boy
asleep clutching the unopened candy in
his hand
he'd been unable to get the staples open
but where had the poison come from
and why would anyone do something so
appalling the police were determined to
find
out and bring the murderer to justice
[Music]
so where are the five poisoned pixie
sticks come from ronald o'brien said
they had come from one of the houses
they'd visited during trick-or-treating
his story was that the children had gone
ahead after
no one initially answered the door but
he stayed behind the door opened a man
handed him the pixie sticks and then
closed the door again ronald caught up
with the children and distributed the
candy at first mr o'brien couldn't
remember which house he'd gotten the
candy from
police interviewed homeowners along the
two streets the group had been
trick-or-treating at
none had given out pixie stix finally
after the third time walking through the
neighborhood
brian finally pointed out the house it
belonged to a man named courtney melvin
police interviewed mr melvin
and he told them he'd been working on
halloween night and hadn't arrived home
until after 11 pm
he was an air traffic controller at one
of houston's airports 200 people had
seen him working that night so his alibi
was rock solid to the detectives
something felt wrong here it didn't make
sense that a random stranger in this
nice suburban neighborhood
would randomly give out poisoned candy
to kill children for that matter the
only person they knew for a fact that
the poisoned candy in their possession
was ronald o'brien so they began to take
a closer look at timothy's supposedly
grieving
father
ronald clark o'brien aged 30 had never
had any run-ins with the law before
in fact he appeared to be a model
citizen he was a deacon at the second
baptist church he also sang in the choir
he and his family appeared to have
the perfect middle class white picket
fence lifestyle that would have been the
envy of many but
as police peered beneath the surface
they discovered all
was not well with ron o'brien he had a
short fuse and
thus found it difficult to hold down a
job in the past 10 years he'd had
21 different jobs he was suspected of
stealing from his current job with a tso
and was close to being fired from there
as well
he also had a history of spending vastly
beyond his means
and was currently over one hundred
thousand dollars in debt
he was so far behind in repaying these
debts he was close to losing the family
home in deer park to his creditors
and then there was the matter of the
life insurance policies having life
insurance on your children was just as
unusual in 1974 as it is today
especially for an amount that far
exceeds the cost of a funeral in january
1974 ron o'brien without telling his
wife
took out ten thousand dollars of life
insurance policies on each of his
children
a month before timothy died his father
increased the amount of coverage on his
and his sister's lives to thirty
thousand dollars
and a few days before the murder the
policy was bumped up again over the
objections of the insurance company to
50 000 for each child
police thought it's strange that a man
who was struggling to save his home from
foreclosure
would take out and pay for life
insurance policies on his children
things looked even worse for mr o'brien
when it was discovered that
mere hours after timothy's death ron
o'brien had called the insurance company
to try and cash in on the policy he held
on his son's life
it was sleazy behavior for sure but
police still found it hard to believe
that a man would murder his own child
for fifty thousand dollars
and if he was trying to kill timothy for
the money why would he give poisoned
candy to four other children as well
one of them is daughter regardless
detectives now had some tough questions
for mr o'brien
o'brien denied having anything to do
with his son's death he still claimed
he'd gotten the poison candy while
trick-or-treating but that story
increasingly didn't add up to
investigators people continued to
provide tidbits of
o'brien's actions over the preceding
weeks and months helping them to paint a
picture one of his customers
at tso was a chemical salesman and he
remembered o'brien asking him about
different poisons including cyanide
at one point asking how much would kill
a person and where he could buy some a
chemical supply store in houston room at
o'brien visiting looking to buy cyanide
he left after learning the
smallest amount available was five
pounds then there was the odd behavior
o'brien exhibited around the pixie stix
on halloween night he seemed oddly jumpy
whenever any children
other than timothy appeared about to
open any of the contaminated candies
at one point he almost vaulted across
the table to prevent one of the other
children from taking the candy out of
timothy's bag
on the other hand his wife told police
that timothy hadn't originally selected
the pixie
stix as his one piece of candy before
bed his father had told him that he
didn't have time to eat the lollipop
he'd originally wanted and then
reached into the bag and pulled out the
poison candy telling him to eat that
instead
more testimony and evidence was found
co-workers told police that o'brien
bragged in the days before the murder
that
his financial situation was about to
turn around a pocket knife was found in
the o'brien home that had residue from
powdered candy on it an
indication that ronald o'brien had used
it to cut open the packages in order to
add the poison
and he was overheard on the day of
timothy's funeral saying that he
intended to use the money from his dead
son's life insurance policy
to take a vacation and make other large
purchases
police now believe that ronald o'brien
had murdered his son timothy for
financial gain in an attempt to cover
his tracks he distributed poison candy
to other children
apparently not caring if they died too
perhaps
in the case of his daughter he even
hoped for it so he could collect on her
policy as well
it was one of the most appalling crimes
that anyone involved had ever
encountered
ronald o'brien was arrested on november
5th six days after the murder as the
press caught winds of what he had done
they soon dubbed him the candyman
o'brien was charged with one count of
capital murder and four counts of
attempted murder he pleaded not guilty
to all charges still claiming his
innocence his defense consisted entirely
of the urban legend of the random
halloween poisoner
despite the fact that no stranger had
ever killed a child with poison
trick-or-treat candy either
before timothy o'brien's death or even
in the decades since then
leading to today despite the fact that
the prosecution had no definitive proof
of where ronald o'brien had gotten the
poison they alleged he used
they believed their case was strong
enough without it it was built on ronald
o'brien's own words and actions his
apparent fascination with cyanide buying
and boosting life insurance policies and
his bizarre behavior
on the night of halloween on june 3 1975
he was found guilty on all counts after
the jury had
only deliberated for 45 minutes he was
sentenced to death and sent to state
prison in huntsville
70 miles north of houston to await his
execution the other death row inmates
detest
him child murderers not being popular in
the prison population
o'brien maintained his innocence to the
very end on march 31
1984 after exhausting all his appeals
ronald clark o'brien was executed by
lethal injection a crowd had gathered
outside the prison
some protesting the death penalty others
in support of it
when it was announced that o'brien was
dead some of the demonstrators shouted
trick-or-treat and showered the
protesters with candy
[Music]
the death of timothy o'brien had a big
impact on his community shortly after
the trial daniel bryan filed for divorce
she later remarried and she and her new
husband raised her daughter elizabeth
avoiding questions from reporters
for years afterwards the residents of
pasadena and deer park did not
participate in trick-or-treating and
had a hard time celebrating halloween at
all the trauma of the murder
having shaken them so badly despite the
fact that timothy had been killed by his
father in an
insurance scheme and that halloween
candy was only an excuse to
poison him the murder still breathed new
life into the old urban legend of
the random halloween poisoner propelling
it to new heights
every year the stories got more
horrifying and more outlandish poisoned
candy razors and needles embedded in
apples drugs
and candy throughout the 1980s the media
whips the public into a panic with
constant warnings about
tempered trick-or-treat goodies to the
point that one poll indicated 60 percent
of american parents feared that their
children would be harmed by it
this was only one part of an overall
hysteria that gripped america during the
1980s surrounding child safety and
stranger danger
while this led to some positives such as
the creation of the national center for
missing and exploited children
it also had negatives such as falsely
accusing several daycare employees of
sexually abusing children for halloween
changes were made as well some
communities stopped having
trick-or-treating altogether
for those that did new guidelines were
put into place children and parents were
encouraged to only accept candy in
sealed brand name packaging turning away
from homemade treats and things like
that other community organizations such
as schools churches and clubs came up
with the trunk or treat as an
alternative to traditional
trick-or-treating a trunk or treat is
held in a parking lot made up mostly of
adults who
already know each other supposedly
making things safer for children whether
or not
you think trick-or-treating is dangerous
at least when it comes to poison
halloween candy
it seems that parents were trying to
protect their children from a threat
that simply didn't exist dr joel best a
sociologist from the university of
delaware did an extensive study on the
halloween poison legend and found no
documented cases of a stranger giving
children poisoned halloween candy
the few examples of children who died
from eating poison candy
were like timothy o'brien given it by
someone they knew
best found that the vast majority of
supposedly poisoned candy cases are
hoaxes many thought up by the children
themselves as a way to get attention
despite this the myth persists to this
very day and continues to evolve
the modern iteration revolves around
marijuana edibles gummies or
candies with marijuana in them that both
police and the media claim might end up
in children's trick-or-treat bags either
by mistake or on purpose
as per usual no evidence of this
occurring has been found
ronald clark o'brien remains one of
america's most infamous killers he took
advantage of a playful children's
holiday to commit a horrific crime and
in the process
changed the way we celebrate halloween
and in fact
the way we view strangers especially
when it comes to our children it is why
in some circles
ronald o'brien is known as the man who
killed halloween
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe also please do check out my
new podcast
the casual criminalist links are below
and thank you for watching